افادت مصادر دبلوماسيه للجزيره ان روسيا
وزعت على اعضاء مجلس الامن الدولي مشروع
قرار يطلب من الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو اجراء تحقيق الدولي في التخريب
الذي تعرضت له خطوط انابيب
وتحديد من يقف وراء العمليه المصادر اضافه
ان البعثه الروسيه ترغب في ان يتم التصويت
على مشروع القرار الاسبوع المقبل وحصلت
الجزيره على نسخه من مشروع القرار الروسي
الذي يطلب من غوتيريش انشاء لجنه تحقيق
دوليه بهذا الخصوص مشروع القرار يشير الى
ان الهجوم على خطوط الانابيب وقع بعد ان
وجهت الولايات المتحده تهديدات متكرره ضد
موسكو دعت سابقا الى عقد جلسه مفتوحه
لمجلس الامن الدولي في الثاني والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري لمناقشه ما تصفها موسكو
بمعلومات جديده متعلقه بتخريب